a child approaches the President of the
European Parliament doesn't speak the
same language that is actually speaking
backwards he doesn't have a coat I was
cold these were the scenes in lesbos in
Greece on the visit of President Martin
Schulz at a refugee reception center the
center's are tasked with filtering the
legitimate and illegitimate asylum
claims and proceed with relocating those
given the green light within the EU it
is a extreme difficult it is a dramatic
situation I think agrees alone is for
sure not able to manage the whole
problem no hot spot will help us to
solve the problem if there is not a
sustainable relocation system at the end
we need also clear understanding with
Turkey by 2017 and 160 thousand refugees
are to be relocated from Italy and
Greece to other EU countries despite
opposition from Romania the Czech
Republic Slovakia and Hungary real
situation will be to stop the war in
Syria and to stop the refugee flows and
then to have an agreement with Turkey in
order to organize better the
resettlement mechanism on the 4th of
November the first group of 30 refugees
were relocated from Greece to Luxembourg
among them were 16 children at the end
of the visit the young boy named Syed
had received a warm coat his boldness
was rewarded
my